siamo tornati su inside videogame della
vita mi sta piacendo da morire ragazzi
non so che cazzo dirmi ed epico camera
che vi lascio al video l'ex co porca eva
em up e dai però ragazzi che nervi porca
eva che badano ammazzerei ditemi che lo
posso buttare giù dallo strapiombo dopo
l'ammasso ah ho capito fermi cazzo mi ha
visto bene solista [ __ ] dai
sentivo io lo faccio arrivare qua poi
lui riesce a saltare sopra ma come lo
zucca bene salta salta ce l'ho fatta ce
lo farei adesso che fa asso controllando
lo zombie di sopra perfetto ma dai è
storia
che figata vai vai zio lazio è zio e mi
è andata ancora bene che non era un cane
suicida se non a costo di morire si
buttava per aggiornarmi pure devo
saltare sopra
io lo zombie lo zombie sul caso io
controllo lo zombie che controlla un
altro zombie cioè uno zombie cep shaun
quindi io che cosa devo fare spiega qual
è il mio obiettivo adesso faccio così
devo fare a questa parte ok perfetto
così io adesso mi stacco lo capite è
assurdo sto gioco se deve diventare uno
zombie cifra non certo punto ragazzi io
ve lo dico non capirò più un cazzo
quindi speriamo di no non mi hanno visto
non mi stanno vedendo
ma c'è un ragazzino che va di moonwalk
nel vuoto e voi non lo state vedendo non
so se vi rendete conto
ha capito che sono di sopra però io
adesso mi butto giù a ho capito dove
tira la leva ho capito ho capito vito
veloce zio prima che facciano qualcosa
però veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
valdisotto veloce fra chi è mi va di
culo che c'è sempre l'acqua di sotto se
no veramente incazz ti ami salvo che si
chiama se siamo usciti d'asta fabbrica
vi prego mi piace veramente un'ansia
incredibile
evidentemente no cosa che devo fare qua
ma che cazzo è una diga
ok si è aperta una porta che culo è
andata bene che avevano abbassato il
livello dell'acqua adesso lo alzo così
perfetto vai l'escaut a rallentare c'è
qualcuno lassù ciao zio hai voglia di
prendermi un autobus su qualcosa no
siamo in autostrada in chi ha passato un
treno sarà il successore santo iddio
quanta gente sa chi mi ha preso così è
successo da dove maraffa c'era uno di
quei cose che ti sparano cavi elettrici
perfetto mettiamoci qua ok
vai veloce gira gira gira gira veloce
veloce la cena veloce non ci arriva non
ce l'ho io ci arrivo
che culo che culo mi sono salvato al
pelo al pelo incredibile vai adesso
interessa la dovrei fare in teoria e se
non sono troppo frettoloso
ce l'ho fatta porca eva ciao ragazzi a
posto mi dà il 50 di rompere le palle a
qualcun altro perché solo io ma in tutto
il mondo sono io l'unico deficiente
libero cioè come è possibile
poi devo alzare la botola prima che
arrivi dovrei farcela in teoria ma
quanti carichi pieni di gente che
arrivano c'è assurdo qualunque sia la
trama di questo gioco ragazzi e
raccapricciante c'è assurdo veramente
madonna che ansia dai ragazzi siamo
arrivati fin qua prima o poi arriveremo
da qualche parte che mi spiega che cosa
sta succedendo io lo so io me lo sento
perché se no non ha senso di esistere
sto gioco sorry saroyan gun mani e nei
centri bifani bar alert and roll e
chiude i momò io lo so che muoio lo so
che muoio
sono vivo il solito quando faccio sti
esperimenti credo sempre invece così
oddio pensavo fossero che facevano sesso
invece sono dei cani che mangiano
qualcosa è probabilmente se mi scoprono
mangiano anche me però vabbè tanto non
mi vedono amiche l'ambientazione uguale
a penombra sta succedendo a sti cani che
problemi hanno sti cani sicuro se mi
attaccano adesso sicuro mi butto in
acqua tanto non mi raggiungono in acqua
convinto pupa melo pupa melo tutto io
non ho parole
io non ho parole 6 magica tanto lo so
che se vado avanti mi incula quindi
faccio così si tuffa si tuffa si tuffa
guardate ostinato al limite proprio
maremma maiala bu raiola ci sarà o no
semplicemente lo giro perfetto per
settore effetto perfetto vai vai veloce
veloce veloce prima che esca
dimmi che c'è qualcosa sicuramente c'è
un precipizio dove devo saltare convinto
lo sapevo io io le sole cose ragazzo
mesi
quantomeno poppate cazzo togli le travi
porca eva porque porque porque hay ma
porca ho sbagliato vabbè non mi prendono
per il culo dai per sé io riesco ok vai
vai veloce veloce veloce veloce quanto
sono inferociti sti cazzo di cani 11 ma
solo una sola roba porca eva porca
quanto [ __ ] ai vai vai dentro
veloce o michiara difficile anche i cani
che potrebbero passare tranquillamente
lavoro scaffale prova per ragazzi
qualcuno vi frega i prossimi comics
qualcuno mi faccia un costo di come sto
tizio vi prego non è neanche difficile
basta figurarsi la faccia di bianco
mettere i capelli neri tipo pasquale
praticò e x6 quasi questi qua piano
piano piano piano il suo scappa veloce
scappa
ok perfetto va beh mi ci sono buttato
sopra se chiusi il sottomarino a jesolo
tu michele gatti poi gta è infilata no
vabbè sono col sottomarino bellissimo va
bene ragazzi il comandante i nautilus fa
vj arriverà a destinazione alle 14 in
punto
prima però faremo una pausa al mcdonald
che ho fame fase spunto nell'oceano
atlantico disperso dove non c'è nessuno
sono contento ragazze vai giù forte
perfetto sfondo have a break quanto è
figo sto gioco atto sta diventando bello
minchia ragazzi se io fossi veramente lì
dentro
avrei una cagà bruttissima questa è una
delle mie fobie
se mi trovo in questa situazione nella
vita reale io muoio lì dentro ci greco
ok sfondato un muro tra l'atro non so
neanche dove sto andando probabilmente
troverò atlantide oi resti del titanic
non so uno dei due leve noi e lo so mare
maiello sommari o sfondato ma le cover
ginato un muro malissimo però sono
sfondando un muro completamente a caso
va bene sapevo che sarebbe servito a
qualcosa sfor buco perfetto medaglia
d'oro di nuoto por che vede da quando
iniziato il gioco che sono più in acqua
che fuori incredibile ho adesso non
voglio vedere un cristiano in giro è
mica mi sono fatto due chilometri sotto
l'oceano se c'è un cristiano in giro a
mi incazzo perché è assurdo
dove stiamo andando e su perfetto
salve allora devo cliccare sicuro sto
tasto propri ma fatemi vedere cosa c'è
là su non ci arrivo clic col tasto porca
eva porca perché io questa sfida sempre
in tutte le cose perché sono vivo oddio
cosa va beh ma che ansia ragazzi che
ansia io fossi stato in lui avrei cristo
nato tre o quattro volte perché mi
piacciono in una foresta
cos'è sta roba sicuramente sono fuori
dalla portata di quei deficienti di
prima che mi seguivano poi non lo so
spero di sì almeno questa roba ma salta
salta bellissimo mi chiamo voglio si
compra su amazon so cosa c'è un voto
perché dovunque vado ci sono bottoni non
facciamoci domande schiacciamo tasti a
caso si è aperto cosa che sia aperto
cos'è sta roba
ancora ma cosa cosa me ne faccio tornato
vero prima sotto sotto vai vai vai
veloce veloce ha visto anche lei scusi
c'è un mostro marino un mostro delfino
mostro qualcosa da queste parti io sono
fa vj e sono pacifico tiro le testate
forti così c'era un pezzo di muro c'era
ho preso quello ai forza zio forza
ma chi è tra l'altro i tizi a cui ai
quali ho [ __ ] sottomarino se ne
saranno accorti che gli ho potuto
sottomarino perché mi piacciono tre ore
che ce l'ho io nel secondo non se n'è
accorto nessuno ai vai vai vai vai
sfonda tutto di fatto è una bambina
credo sia una bambina dai capelli
cos'è samara catering no non lo metterei
dentro non spaccare il vetro cioè che
ora da ragazzi che un proprio episodio
di inside di bello che conclude gli
episodi tipi di piace questa cosa che
non lascia niente in sospeso vero però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi punti però
nel prossimo episodio bombardati dai
kings vinto cose che vi è piaciuto
l'argomento è un mi piace anche la pace
di facebook con i video della realtà ciò
sicuramente meno fiato del tipo che
nuota sott'acqua senza vestiti siete
riusciti diavolo sia vito è da ragazzi